cast of a new show at the Venetian  surprising some students at the Las  Vegas Academy of the Performing Arts  today this is so cool we were talking  about the cast of freestyle Love Supreme  [Applause]  [Laughter]  look at them that's right lin-manuel  Miranda that's right he was there he was  in town he of course is the co-creator  of the show all right once they settle  down they talk to students about the  show their personal pass into the world  of theater as well  it's incredible to have him here because  he's such a Trailblazer in the theater  community and he's written so many  things that have just been incredible  and things that have changed the way  that students look at theater  if you were interested in seeing the  show it does run now through next April